We have just created a graphic using DimpleJS around the World Cup
attendance throughout it's history.
We have learned about how to best choose a chart given our data and
its structure, and some of the theory and formalism around this
process both from Edward Tufte, and LuAnn Wilkinson's Grammar of Graphics.
>> You also saw many examples of data visualization.
In particular, you saw how the design choices that you didn't make can either
enhance or hinder you ability to communicate effectively with an audience.
>> Next we'll be going over a few ways that you can effectively tell your
data story.
Also, different narrative structures that you can use when
creating complex interactive visualizations.